[Music]
welcome and good morning bachelor nation
this is et live and we are here with
Nick vile round of applause in the
studio for Nick vile Nick right.you well
I applaud yourself sure why not it's
weird no one else claps Nick I haven't
seen you in a minute
I'm so glad you're here because we are
going to recap last night's episode of
The Bachelorette and if you guys haven't
seen it yet Nick is doing some hilarious
recaps of The Bachelorette himself check
them out as well with the injured with
Dina and Jared putting them up yourself
and it's called the bad chiller is that
the official name yeah we just call it
we just you know real fast
very real fast the bad chiller so we're
gonna get your thoughts and of course we
want to know what you guys thought of
last night's episodes so send your
comments and questions in on any of ET
social media platforms I will get them
here on our wonderful iPad and we'll get
Nick's take on things and catch up with
you on some stuff great so let's dive
right in
first I want to talk to you Nick about a
gentleman named Colton
so guys last night Tiye of course
Becca's friend Tia from ole Weiner
Arkansas made an appearance with some of
Becca's other gals on the show and we
had to discuss the fact that Tia and
Colton had dated in the past is Tia also
from Wiener attina
Tia is from wiener Arkansas yeah yeah
and Colton what do you think Colton's a
wiener think of his intentions Nick
because he have flat out acknowledged
that she thought that maybe Colton dated
her because he thought she was gonna be
the Bachelorette and my question there
is well why do you date someone if you
think they're about to go date a bunch
of other people if you're really into
them I don't know I've only heard
secondhand information
what's your secondhand information I
don't believe it but I've heard he
claims that she reached out to him okay
if that's true that would be like
totally random like what are the odds
which she reached out to him because she
thought she was gonna be The Bachelor I
don't know okay I just heard he claimed
through to other people that she is the
one who contacted him which would seem
really ironic like
yeah happened to come across them again
he's a good-looking guy
who just happened to also be in the
process of casting for the next season
it's a small world after all
it would be really confident though he's
very safe with his words Colton
there was a part in last an episode I
don't remember the specific one but he
was like having a guy chat and they were
talking about it and you could tell as
he was talking he'd like stop to think
about what he should say and then spoke
in some platitude like well I'm just
very grateful or humbled or whatever
vulnerable whatever like thing he's just
like when he was going to go on the show
like just say how humbled and grateful
you are all the time which a lot of
people do you can tell he was doing that
at this point with how much people can
reach out to other people who have been
on the show or maybe even like do
producers give you any advice in advance
what do you say is kind of the advice or
the thought process that people go into
the show with as a contestant like do
they just think okay I've got us say I'm
open and vulnerable and I've got to be
in that place or how do people enter the
show I don't know I can't speak for
everyone everyone's different yeah I
think there's a lot of people and you
see it more and more now like with
social media as you see people come on
who who think they're supposed to play a
role I think that people who have the
most success is the people who don't
think about the cameras and just kind of
let themselves be a part of that insane
process yeah and sometimes you know say
things that they you know how should I
have said that or not like few people go
in there and just kind of immerse
themselves and necessarily worry about
how they might come across I think over
time usually other people who come
across as the most authentic and
sometimes you see people you can tell
they're just you know saying what like
you know that's like week two and
they're like hey I just like ever was
episode two and Lincoln it was like
there may be their second time talked
and he's just like I'm I'm my best self
when I'm around you and I'm like how do
you it's been five seconds literally
probably talked for 12 minutes total yes
I've done one activity she wasn't even a
part of it somehow he's in his best self
I mean it's like it's lines like that
when you hear people early on you're
like oh he's full of [ __ ] can I swear
I'm sorry no you well you just it's
great I mean if you were really gonna
give a time - how much time saved by
week three that you've the
lead has spent with a contestant well
three is like day eight okay so by and
by that much time maybe anyone who's had
a one-on-one it's had some like a good a
day got spend some nice time and and
that person those people usually there
they start feeling a connection you and
things do happen fast and there's a lot
of guys who at that point have maybe
spent literally five minutes with her
okay maybe that is maybe I mean because
they say they're like you've got to get
vulnerable and intense and open really
quickly is because you have five minutes
with this person we got it there's only
so much time there's so many people you
know it's just natural that the leads
gonna connect with certain people I get
the feeling that Colton is aware of the
cameras I was very aware that he's very
rich Aly Raisman yeah so that's the
thing motivated several people just like
no I mean listened I'll think about
Colton to is he's no different and I
know we teased him on our recaps about
like yeah this whole like he's got this
charity
he's clearly aware of like his brand and
brand aware he's brand new air okay
right yeah it doesn't make him a bad guy
not a bad guy and it's no different than
any other guy who went on the show they
didn't know Becca and everyone goes for
the experience you know it's almost a
little insane to like not know back I'd
be like well I I'm here for Becca you
know like they don't know her like I
think everyone has to be open to it
what percentage of people would you say
when they are like what's the percentage
of people who know who the lead is based
on when casting happens what's different
with the Bachelorette yeah they didn't
know announced Becca until by the time
they announced Becca the guys are
already in the hotel days away from okay
being casted they might get a heads up I
knew it was Andy after I accepted to
come but before I left so the bachelors
a little different because they usually
announce it with like a month before
filming so the women tend to know so
they mix it up a little so it's
different for bachelor and bachelorette
but yeah the guys they're all they don't
for sure and they agree to come most of
the time well we'll see what happens
with Colton and Becca I think that Becca
is very attracted to Colton yeah and the
episode to it she's like I feel this
connection with you and that's like
we're like well you feel a connection
with his face right she's into like
beefy guys as well remember her ex Ross
from when he came to re-season and I've
the other that beefy you don't think it
was like I don't know probably like 510
511 okay he was husky misty wants to
know Nick who do you think will be the
last man standing at the end of all this
a big question for Nick I don't know she
seems to have right now and so it's
early I mean it seems to be Blake and
Garrett Garin yeah well I mean the
reality is the Garrett got the first
impression rose and when it comes to the
Bachelorette I don't think I haven't I
only started watching on Desiree's
season when she was right before mine
and including Desiree's season I think
Brooks got it so the guy who's gotten
and it's very different on The Bachelor
but the guy who gets the first
impression hasn't finished less than
number three why do you think that is
why with women is it that first
impression that I don't know women just
have great intuition well you know for
not necessarily like I instantly felt a
connection with Vanessa but for me I did
you know like I knew I felt the
connection so she was the only person I
wasn't gonna give the first impression
rose to that was from my choice but like
explain that a little bit no I just knew
I had a like it was like I felt an
immediate connection with what got a
limo I was like okay you know and so
other than that I just wanted to for me
it was more about who surprises me that
I wasn't expecting as soon as I started
talking to Rachel I felt a connection
too and so I wanted to give it to her
but I knew I was going to be into
Vanessa and I didn't want to put a
target on her back kind of thing so I
was just like she's the own
as soon as you got a limo she's I'm like
not getting there first impression rose
and that was me everyone's different and
I can't speak for why the Bachelorette
bachelorettes give and to their person I
heard a rumor and I realized I've never
asked you for clarity on this I heard
that you wore that bracelet from you and
Vanessa's gravity date like the whole
season
is just a sign you know you really cared
about it the whole time maybe so you did
to go back and watch the footage okay so
many questions coming in a shamble from
YouTube wants to know how come Jordan
said he shambled what a great YouTube
name checked his phone but phones
weren't allowed I noticed that too I
went back and watched it he checked his
phone well he said I found I got it it
sounded a little bit like he said I got
a notification today that I had 4,000
but he said one day I got a notification
in the past
did you know contestants who had phone
I've heard they usually get caught okay
it's kind of silly too because you know
I obviously have been on a few times and
like once you realize you've been in you
know you could figure out ways of like
how maybe you could get away of sneaking
around but honestly it's not worth it
you know you kind of again you have to
really just be a part of the process
like what are you gonna do like talk to
you're like there's really no upside to
sneaking in a phone yeah that was always
my philosophy I like that good advice
yeah Nina says that Colton reminds her
of Jordan from Jo Jo season because he's
very careful with his words and guarded
well yeah we'll see what happens with
Colton I I think that that physical
attraction goes a long way so I think
he's gonna be around for he's very yeah
Colton like he's I've heard from people
from the show that he's a good guy so I
don't you know but he you know it seems
like he's like hiding something you know
Josh Murry in there you know like a
little like talks about charities alive
good-looking always seems to be above
the fray what was last time you talked
to Josh Murry
it's been a while it's been a while are
you guys like if you saw him how would
that interact fine good no care that's
all like you know we're we don't hang
out but sure okay so let's talk about a
little hospital incident moment we had
we loved an ambulance I mean not really
but you know the non serious serious
injury yes isn't that a wonderful I
don't know if Tropes the right word I
mean it seemed like David really was
hurt it was funny cuz like Kris is like
hey he's in was it they say intensive
intensive care intensive care which is
like no doesn't mean anything but then
it's like we're gonna call him let's
call him and then you get some the phone
he's like
what's up Becca how's it going like oh
god he's fine
hi that's why I was bad I'm like we see
the blood props to producers or whoever
it was for not cleaning up the bloody
and you're getting those shots that
bloody towel was there and then you know
we just gave him a call and I see you
then he's fine and he was good and we've
seen him on Instagram now and David is
fine I interviewed she said everybody's
fine yeah before we spoofed it we
actually did check his Instagram be like
how fine and they blurred his face but I
guess we'll find out just how messed up
his face is okay and David and Jordan
also had a lot of drama with their
little quarrel at with the tinder thing
as we mentioned I I feel that David is
in over his head here or maybe they both
do you know when someone makes Jordan
look smart
you know you're losing yeah David's so
obsessed that's the problem with that
world sometimes people go in there and
it's good to be snarky and it's good to
be funny and kind of observe your peers
and kind of like tease them I suppose
but like David is clearly like David's
got gone on the show and thought to
himself Jordans the villain Jordans that
he's the idiot he's I'm gonna make I'm
gonna look better by making fun of him
and all he like in that world you you
should just let people kill themselves
so to speak you know and you're just
trying to do what he doesn't need to do
and he's looking terrible doing it the
other guy thought he's obnoxious there
was that moment when he turned to the
other guys and he was like this is funny
right you think this is funny like oh no
was it wills well he was my favorite
just sitting there yeah you could tell
you this like why am I here
this is you'd like immediate like regret
from the whole I mean I know dude these
are my these are my peers this rat I
wanted to ask you what you think sort of
overall of the show and how it's going
because Corinne from your season she was
on a Sirius XM radio show recently and
she said quote about the show it's just
the show doesn't seem to be working
anymore does the show does it suck that
the show only was great because of
drinking it's like one drink per two
hours or something like that now and now
the drama is just like trying too hard
so I wanted to get your take on that
because
and we do we ever take anything currency
seriously you don't do you well I think
it's an interesting point about how the
scandal might have changed things I mean
it was acknowledged by production the
first place yes the bachelor in paradise
I don't think it's really any different
and I honestly think the show is never
really relied on people getting drunk I
mean usually if there is a drunken
situation it's almost always night one
in Karen's situation it was the first
day of filming because people show up
they're nervous and bachelor and
bachelorette world they don't know what
to expect there but like name times
before the scandal where like a drunken
situation was highlighted that's a
really good point I just make such a big
deal about it silly I think I think
Curran wants her legacy to live on but
like she's you know there have been
people like her before they'll boo
people like her afterwards she was a you
know a great contestant but I mean so
you think the show is just as good as
ever I mean listen I think there there's
seasons that are have better ratings in
others I don't know how this one's doing
I'm enjoying this season you know it's
tough I mean that as far as the French
has it goes how I mean how many long has
it been on for it for it to be as
relevant as it is now is incredible it's
there's variations of every season but
ultimately it's the same every season
you know and it's good because people
love it and you have different
characters every season but having been
someone who's been on you know
Bachelorette Paradise and bachelor
you've done them all is there anything
you'd like to see the show try anything
new or different you ever shoot a text
like hey what about a date like this or
an idea like this Oh sometimes I don't
remember anything specific but I think
the producers are good at what they do
and they're all very creative I mean I I
personally like it when the show does a
good job of not taking itself too
seriously they've done a better job of
that that you obviously is that a lot in
Paradise because it is a comedy as much
as it is a drama in a love story and I
like it when they show some you know
humor in the show but yeah I think as
long as they keep doing that they'll be
fine but we had great moments I totally
disagree with Corinne almost always oh
okay well let me read one other quote
Corinne said she was asked specifically
about you and she said I am sad to say
unfortunately that not just me a lot of
people have said this he just seems so
miserable in person he's just not really
that nice I haven't talked to Corinne
since I sent her home she did slide in
my DMS a couple weeks ago what did she
say well in a flirtatious way or I mean
it was like at 1:30 in the morning I
didn't respond okay that's fair yeah I
mean a a lot of people have said this I
felt like that was well I mean maybe
name some names or see what's happening
here so okay you you are compared to
confirm you are not miserable that's
what she said she said a lot of people
have said this he just seems so
miserable in person it was like what are
the Corinne says whatever she can say to
good attention that's fair
okay okay not well I think that uh I
think her in is good at getting
attention yeah she post a picture of my
hometown yes like that's she's good at
that does it frustrate you I don't
really care yeah I mean this is what she
does well yeah it's like I mean people's
turns gray it's got to be kind of crazy
to be because I think about this so much
that Instagram especially has changed
the fame longevity of everyone on this
show some in some ways great and in some
ways like I mean you are constantly
having to deal with what I'm doing right
now which is asking you about something
an ex of yours said and you haven't
actually seen her in months like is that
once I haven't seen her and I literally
haven't seen her since I sent her home
so that's got to be kind of yeah well I
mean you if you're gonna be a part of
this franchise you just kind of have to
take things with a grain of salt I mean
so god I've been through the ups and
downs yeah I mean you can't win them all
you know some like and again ly gonna
take in this world it's always important
to remember where you came from the
people who are always gonna be the most
important to your friends and family or
those are people's opinions you care
about and
those are the people who come to you and
say hey you know Nick or whoever you are
you know like why you being this way or
give you some like critical feedback
then I think it's important to pay
attention to those people but everyone
else has their own perspective or you
know an outsider's point of view or
maybe they just want attention
well highs and lows like you said what
was looking back I mean you've got a
little distance from it now toughest
moment for you during all the shows that
you filmed why did you have to work
through the most it's hard I mean what's
hard I don't know I mean like when
you're when you're in that environment
and you have real feelings it's
impossible it's impossible yeah I mean
like because you don't know how to
process it yeah you know I mean again
like for example like when I was on
Kaitlin season and all the drama between
Sean and I all it really was was two
guys who really just cared about a girl
who just hated the fact that they kind
of sense that you know there was they
weren't the only one there was a
connection right they didn't we didn't
know how much or whatever and like you
know and so that that's a miserable
feeling and you don't know how to
process that and that's a really hard
thing because you really care about
someone and you realize this is a messed
up situation you have to be okay with
things that you would never be okay with
in the outside world and that's it's a
terrible and hard process to go through
are you able to get in any little
moments where you can really show
someone like I'm really into you or is
it just you're constantly surrounded by
people are you talking like as The
Bachelor yeah it's hard because I think
you got to be careful with that I think
leads have made the mistake of maybe
saying things off-camera that they
shouldn't say making promises you know
maybe even to more than one person you
never want to get too confident I mean I
think sometimes the lead can make the
mistake of if let's say for example the
lead were too and weak their first
one-on-one be like I I'm pretty sure I'm
gonna pick this right they still have to
go on 101 dates and they have the lead
has to challenge themselves as much as I
liked Vanessa and I knew she was going
to go far I I had to challenge
self - you know and I knew I had
connection with rate show and Raven and
it was just like I had to make sure I
had to forget about that and no matter
what you think that's gonna mess with
the person so you could go up to someone
and say like if I were and I didn't say
this to Vanessa but if I were to say
you're the your head she had never done
that before
and now all of a sudden he's like he
just told me I was it I just saw him go
he's like making it you know and said
that will really mess with your psyche
so you never want to give too much
conference to that person it will
destroy them you know and I think that
you've seen I think some people get too
confident it it really messes with them
is that the biggest mistake you can make
as a lead to do that think you made a
lot of mistakes that would be a big one
yeah I think that would be it's a huge
mistake - if it's one thing to make them
feel confident someone you know like you
want to reassure them like hey listen
just just trust me kind of thing you
know I mean I can't really say more than
that but just try to relax is that's a
big difference than saying listen I'm
gonna pick you you that's really gonna
mess with you because you're you're
you're gonna trust someone you haven't
known for that long
and then you're also in this world and
you're thinking like is are they for
real I think they're for real but like
it can really mess with you
I remember there was a moment on Caitlyn
season where we kind of saw behind the
scenes moment with Sean talking to a
producer and he was like dude you're my
only friend here like I'm so in and I
remember being like this is such a real
moment he really is so confused in all
this right now yeah and again like Sean
just really cared about Palin yeah it
was just a messed up thing and you know
it was a he you you can criticize like
people who seem like they're losing
their moment but like at least those are
the people who are most sincere well I
don't want to shock you but you're
bringing up Vanessa and a lot of people
want to know where you guys stand I know
your cordial you're good yeah we're
friends I mean we were not really in
each other's lives you know we have a
lot of mutual friends we we don't cross
paths it's been a while since there's
been any communication but obviously
we've we left things on very good terms
and the last time you spoke was kind of
a friendly I don't remember what the
context was but I think one of us asked
the other person something you know is
this we're there for each other but like
right now it it's not the place you
I heard she's dead like she has other
people in her life and in that sense it
just doesn't make sense for us to
actively be in each other's lives but
yeah
was that hard to hear that she was
dating someone else no I mean we broke
up on good terms I think we both
accepted that we weren't the right fit
for each other
and we both wanted try to be happy and
so I certainly want her to be so the
fact that she's dating someone I'm
really excited for I know you guys were
dealing with a lot you did the
long-distance thing and you know
everybody says coming off the show is so
hard what do you think it really was
that made you know we've tried here but
this isn't gonna work I mean I'm not
getting into the details there wasn't
long distance she basically lived in LA
so I had nothing to do with that I
thought she had to go back to Canada a
lot no I know I mean we went and visited
Canada a few times but for the most part
she was anyway it was just just not the
right fit you know yeah so what do you
do now I wonder the salaat how do you
date once you're a lead off of this show
because I would imagine if you go grab
coffee with someone and the paparazzi
get pictures of it then it turns into
something so do you try to date people
quietly first do you use dating apps
like how do you date now I don't know I
struggle you know it's a challenge I
don't I'm not on any dating apps nothing
I'm like adverse to it yeah dating apps
are a mainstream thing then a lot of
people have met their husband or wife so
there's I'm just I'm very protective of
that I don't know because you know I'm
open to dating anyone that I feel
connection with so whether that's
someone who has no connection to the
spotlight or the bachelor world or you
know just it just it just depends you
know but it can be weird sometimes
because if I were say on a date with
someone who really has no connection
with any type of like public persona
like you know sometimes people come up
and they always try to be cool it can be
awkward it's difficult sometimes but I
mean for the most part I don't really
think too much of it or I try to make a
big deal about it I'm just the same kid
from Milwaukee yeah well no I would just
it's like I'm sure and then if you do
date someone else who's also a public
persona again you go out somewhere I
mean we get paparazzi photos sent to us
all the time I think you're a little bit
more protective yeah
and you don't like you kind of yeah
Elaine from facebook says well Nick are
you seeing anyone
I am not currently seeing anyone okay
dating seeing what happens busy with a
lot of other stuff well zoo Ella what a
cool name says would you ever do
paradise again no I mean not as a cast
member you know maybe I'll you know I I
won't be on this season I think but if
there's ever like a fun cameo that is
creative or whatever just to help
support the show I'm all for it you know
I'm still a fan of the franchise and you
know think finally back think back on my
time very fondly but as a cast member on
I I've proven at least for me while the
show does work for love it doesn't work
for me oh well I mean you did three
seasons I know you just said you know
you're still the kid from Milwaukee but
looking back having this much reality TV
time in your life how did all that
change you how has the whole franchise
changed you overall I mean in my core I
don't think I'm a different person I
have a very different life now I'm doing
different things you know working on
various projects that you know I would
never have done and I have new friends
some from the show some from just moving
out to LA and I'm doing a lot more
creative things and I have never done
before and that's cool obviously I'm
I've been working on acting and having
some success with that and that's been
really cool and nothing that I imagined
doing ten years ago and that's all been
a lot of fun but you know I'm still the
same person but the good stuff and the
bad stuff yeah now the my bad habits are
the same hopefully I have some good
habits and those aren't usually the same
but I don't think it's changed me too
much of a person it's always been very
important to me to kind of stay grounded
and I'm very lucky with the family and
friends that I have to help me do that
well it's been fun to see you do the
acting thing because not many people
from the show I think probably a lot of
people have that aspiration but not many
people actually make it happen and you
did and you've had some really fun roles
what's means you want to lean in and do
these really fun recaps with Jared and
Dean well we kind of it all started like
actually a couple years ago with my the
the fourth person in
this whole like project is my best
friend Kyle and he's the one who him and
I kind of write it and Dean and Jared
kind of give their input it well and
Kyle directs it and shoots it he's the
Kevin yet it's it and so he had this
idea of like recapping it that way a
couple years ago we just kind of laughed
at the idea and then on re-season we did
it at the finale just for fun Dean and
Jared did it it was mostly Dean and I
and Jared shot that and it end up going
viral I got like 9 million views so
they're like well let's just keep doing
it it's fun to do like we're all friends
so we're just we have mostly because we
have fun doing it we're just cracking
jokes and again like we we really love
the show and we respect the process at
the same time it's ridiculous and it's
fun to kind of like keep it light and
kind of highlight some ridiculous parts
of the show and people so far seem to
enjoy it so as long as that happens
we'll keep doing it have you heard from
anyone who you've parodied liked it re
ever reach out or any you can tell that
all the guys from this season are like
some have commented so you can tell like
they're all paying attention to washing
it haven't really heard like no-one's
really complained or anything
it's super fun the wigs are amazing it's
all it's all in good fun we're not
trying to you know we don't really tear
anyone apart we kind of we kind of just
tease the situation more than the people
that's for the most part also getting
some comments on your hair Paris on
YouTube said Nick those curls are really
Wow and Haley says you have the best
hair where do you get it cut and what
you call the style I don't have a name
for the style the guy who cuts my hairs
name is Arthur shameless plug we know
you work set in butoh I think is the
style so Arthur he's great I've been
going to him since I've lived out here
love it you've had like a fabulous
transformation during your time on the
show like the Nick of today is a very
buff and polished Nick versus when you
first went on that seems to be the
perception I don't it's funny I leave it
I don't notice it as much as I mean I
definitely have the beard yes maybe that
helps but I've advised you to get the
beard was that a decision where you were
like I'm changing my look it was
actually prom
Caitlyn because I grew it on Kaitlyn
season and I just have had it since and
I got obviously like I got good feedback
but when I was talking to Kaitlyn before
she went on the show I grew a beard and
she she liked it that was the start of
that but she was the catalyst I don't
you know then everyone else gave me good
feedback well I want to pull up a little
workout video that we pulled from your
Instagram when we have a minute because
I mean the NIC vile oh wow yep very buff
but I've like again I like whatever
thank you but I have like I ran track my
whole life like I've always it's weird
cuz people have this idea that I somehow
I weigh literally the same as I did on
andis season you know within five pounds
well my shirt off a lot of Andi season
hey and now you know I was out of shape
for Kaitlyn season I wasn't planning on
coming it's funny because I've actually
heard that with Arie like I remember on
a year season it was very much played up
in your premiere like I think there was
a shower shot with you I mean you looked
great but I came off a paradise and I
definitely worked out for Paradise and
then I just kept staying in shape yeah
you know cuz I and so and then again
they surprised me by asking me to be the
bachelor but thankfully I just kept
working out so it's like tailing season
it was I was living in Chicago one works
out it's cold yeah and you know and so
it was like an almost like crap them to
come on so they already said that where
he wasn't really planning makes it I'd
heard yeah he wasn't really like ready
so we didn't see a ton of shirtless re
yeah makes I totally buy that yeah I
also want to ask you are you still doing
the polish Ghent I mean your style is so
great and you were doing those boxes
probably no I sold that to my partners
yeah there's nothing going on there it's
just we had a kind of vision
disagreement so I let them have that but
I'm working on some other projects that
I'm not really going to speak to you
right now but he's excited about it
excited about it yeah I have yeah sandy
from facebook says well Nick will you
settle down
what are you looking for in a woman I
hope so I think I don't know if there's
this idea that like I really honestly
look forward to the day I meet someone
that I want to spend the rest of my life
with and
I've always been open obviously I don't
I think more than any point in my life
I'm really eager to meet that person
it's not a matter of like well having
dated and I think the show a lot of
people say makes you analyze yourself a
lot yeah I've always been a little if I
for you like I've met this person what
would be I don't know it's tough I think
that's my challenge too
I mean obviously going on the show it it
can make dating outside of it a little
more challenging I think also as you get
older you get more perspective on what
you like and don't like and then
therefore sometimes I think the negative
aspect could be maybe get too picky
right because when you're younger you
meet someone you feel can actually like
that's the state you know you're great
and then you you know you date and then
often you realize you're grape I don't
like this about you we should break up
you know and you kind of evolve that and
as you get older I think maybe you've
got a little a lot of deal-breakers yeah
I don't try to but it's also I think la
is challenging too in terms of meeting
people that you connect with and that
you find a sincerity between them and so
who knows but I hope I hope it's as soon
as tomorrow but like I'm also at the
same time not going to you know force it
you know um I'd rather wait and find the
right person then then just try to
settle down for the sake of it yeah um I
want to do some rapid fire reactions for
you in question no more current
questions statements that let's see what
next gonna say useless statements from
Curran is that what we're saying so we
have a Ari's GQ interview I wanted to
get your take on this because he's made
some comments about the show he ended
that interview really abruptly if you
saw that yeah and he has said that the
show the his but his breakup with Becca
was teased as unedited he said no it was
edited because they were really pushing
me to stay in the room with her and I
wanted to leave but producer said I
couldn't leave that's kind of what he
said and I just wanted your take on that
as a lead does that feel like a fair
statement to you and what do you think
of the fact that he just kind of ended
that interview I in some ways I
empathize with Arie because he was in a
tough situation
listen I I as much as anyone else I
watched the show
from the beginning of his season
constantly like what is he doing and
saying right so I get that but you know
obviously as fans of the show we have a
way of of exaggerating our reaction to
small like small things on the bachelor
seem like big things in life you know
ultimately and I think Becca said this
you know she's in a better place they
clearly weren't a match some people
break up you know and that's okay and an
re it's hard being the bachelor it's
hard to to make a decision off of very
limited information I don't know what
went into Ari's decision to select Becca
over la Lauren and change his mind
and certainly watching the break-up it
was gut-wrenching and awkward and we're
all watching anything what are you doing
having me in that situation I just don't
think there's a lot can be gained from
it's very easy to blame producers and
very few people well Ari did get it bad
so I do feel bad on that side very few
people just own up to their own mistakes
it's very like and I've said this before
you never hear the contestants saying
thanks guys I know I looked great
this episode but I'm gonna be honest
with you they left out this part that I
was kind of a dick yeah and if they show
the whole thing you might not like me as
much which honestly I think happens more
than the opposite
I think if yes certainly you know I I
was the villain I wasn't happy with that
edit I didn't think it was very accurate
and sit there and blame producers
there's aspects that were true I mean
there's context right but I think more
often than not more people end up
looking better than they otherwise would
and not because they're bad people
things are excited generated like
sometimes you just get certain people's
really nice comments and everyone has
snark and everyone says things sometimes
you know if it's some people times
people like pick their nose and it's not
showed imagine if they decided to show
every time someone picked their nose
they'd be known as the nose picker yeah
you know what I'm saying like it's stuff
like that so people just have a way of
blaming producers I think the producers
sometimes get a bad rap for that I don't
know whether it was or wasn't edited
there was just no upside to it but
it sounds like him and Lauren are happy
I'm very happy for that I it seems like
I would guess they would work out so
okay everyone you know I'm jealous what
about the fact that he they announced
their wedding date just a few days
before Becca's premiere whatever I mean
listen again everyone wants to pile on
Ari but every person in batch the world
it's like Ari wasn't the only one who
announced I don't I don't keep tabs but
I'm willing to bet bet that someone else
in batch ination
announced something you all said you see
us all more during the season you all
want to interview us more when the
seasons going on so it's irrelevant it's
a relevant time I mean this I think
people just want to pile on Ari at this
point I also want to ask you about
jarrod and Ashley both two good friends
of yours where people are you so happy
for them I am yeah it's about time Jared
just kind of Jared Jared even say I
interviewed Jared Jared said I regret
taking this long listen I tease them for
that but at the same time I think it
happened the way it should have you know
maybe it took a little bit longer than
the other why should it but sometimes
things need to happen and they're
probably in a better place now then had
they you know jumped in relationship so
what's it like to be around that kind of
gushy love because when I interviewed
them I was like oh my god super I'm
noxious like I'm like jealous and
annoyed and happy for them at the same
time are you jealous
yeah of course I'm jealous like they're
very in love and they're very happy I
mean they obviously had with each other
what I would love to find so I'm very
jealous and I'm happy for them but like
at definitely envious what's worse and
VSR jealous or what's the better of the
two envious but I'm envious
so are you a little lonely I mean
everyone's lonely sometimes
all right are you never lonely no I am I
mean I'm constantly surrounding myself
from other people with other depressing
like Rin nail that is there and it's you
know it's awesome to see them together
they were just all over each other when
they were here so check that out on our
website if you want to see just two
people gosh all over each other and last
thing I wanted to get your take on if
you will give me the answer other than
yourself your favorite bachelor of all
time and your favorite Bachelorette of
all time should you expect me to
say listen you could just say I'm gonna
go easy I won't don't want to pick
anybody else so I'll just say that I
loved being the bachelor I would never
have said that okay well good he's not
miserable you got favorite bachelor
worried favorite Bachelorette to watch i
weirdly like I didn't enjoy Mari as the
bachelor but it was also like fun to
watch
finally it like I've only seen my I
first started I saw Juan Pablos well
again it's also Juan Pablo is like wow
that's the beauty of the show isn't it
it's even if maybe they're not the best
at finding love it's fun to watch
Bachelorette I don't know I didn't watch
Rachel season I heard she was great yes
probably
I guess Kaitlyn I loved watching Kaitlyn
she's so funny you know she was a little
troublemaker and she you know and
certainly made my life challenging
during that time but I respect Kaitlyn
for for better or worse authentically
being herself and I think over time I
you know for me again like I got myself
in trouble early on but you know for
more time than when I feel like over
time people got to know me and
appreciate like anything you say this
thing about Ashley
you know Ashley's greatest gift and I
give Jared a hard time because Jared
struggles with this you know because
it's very polite and Ashley is her I
admire Ashley so much for just being
herself and at times that have has
caused her to get made fun of and grief
and criticism but what has happened over
time is that what people really do is
really appreciate who she is and then
and really admire her because they
realized this is who she is and oh wait
I'm actually like this too and so you
know those are the people I appreciate
the most and I know you know that
Kaitlyn's very much like that I know
Ashley is like that and I like I like
seeing that with people I love it when
Ashley was here she was wearing a
necklace that just said the word emotion
she owns who she is I think that those
are the best most refreshing people in
this world Nick thank you so much for
being here thank you for having amazing
hair
and for being so funny you guys please
check out us love this is live oh my god
you've noticed why we're getting the
comments I don't know a technology I
thought maybe Nick and Jared and Dean do
these amazing recaps check them out of
course follow Nick on instagram if you
don't already they are so funny and he's
so talented and thank you so much for
being here we're here every Tuesday
morning recapping the Bachelorette
thanks for being with each Eli bye guys
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you